meters from turkeys fortified border
with Syria are the ruins of an ancient
capital buried for millennia this is car
kamesh founded three and a half thousand
years ago once part of the hittite and
neo-assyrian empire emerging from the
earth sculptures of rulers and armies
recent excavations by Italian and
Turkish teams have uncovered some of the
finest mosaics of the ancient world
each city in Turkey has lot some of its
cultural heritage but this site is
something different we have found layer
upon layer of different civilizations
including a village dating back to 6000
BC the site straddles the modern border
40% of it lies unexcavated in Syria a
Turkish military base now sits on top of
the ancient Acropolis it's still a
designated active military zone but from
next year it will be an open-air museum
the regional authorities are confident
the area is now safe a few years ago
this area across the border in Syria
used to be ISIL country the black flag
flying high for all to see this part of
southeastern Turkey is the cradle of
civilization it's believed that car
kamesh is one of the places where
agriculture first appeared but as you
can imagine since the start of the
Syrian war the number of foreign
tourists that venture here has dropped
completely will the opening of this site
encourage people back this is no
ordinary archaeological site it's one
that can change the entire history of
the world in illuminate the late heat
heart era here on the side of the
Euphrates River
we are planning a huge National Park and
the week opening will be held next year
in May before today's frontiers divided
the ancient city this is what
archaeologists believe its walls may
have looked like for generations these
ruins have been hidden from view
indifferent to the rise and fall of
latest civilizations and the war that
still rages not far
from here in Syria near Parker al
Jazeera car kamesh on the turkey Syrian
border